hi I'm Ryan Sumner I'm a chief network
architect with IBM cloud and today I'm
going to help you answer what is a
content delivery network so in short a
content delivery network or CDN is a
service that accelerates Internet
content delivery so in other words the
main benefit of a CDN is that it makes
your website faster so before I get into
describing to you how it accomplishes
that and some of the other benefits
first I want to talk to you about some
of the challenges that we have where we
have users all around the world but we
don't have servers all around the world
and the experience that those users have
due to that dynamic so I've got a simple
diagram here showing a server hosted
down in Dallas this is my website and
then I have users all around the world
so in Sydney I might have five in London
I've got five New York I might have ten
LA I might have ten I've got 30 users
around the world that are accessing my
server and my web site down in Dallas so
let's kind of follow a set of these
users in their journey let's look at
their users down in Sydney they make a
request to the web site they've got an
80 600 mile hike to Dallas and then an
80 600 mile hike back the amount of time
that that takes is usually measured and
measured in milliseconds and just that
round-trip might be about 170
milliseconds for our users up in London
that might be about a hundred
milliseconds our users in in New York
City can probably experience about a
forty forty millisecond round-trip time
and over in LA about thirty so as you
can see the further your way the longer
it takes ultimately the slower the
website will be for you
so this is where the the CDN comes into
play and this is how it actually
accomplishes the the increase in speed
which is by reducing the amount of
distance between the user and the
content or the server providing the
content so what it does by do
that is it places these content delivery
network endpoints in as many locations
around the world as possible and in our
case we're going to assume we've got one
in just about every location where our
users exist so now when the user in
Sydney or London or New York City or LA
tries to access some content its first
retrieved by the content delivery
network service and then distributed
around the world so we have a single
request down to the Dallas server it's
now then distributed all around the
world and our users in London now
instead of going all the way to Dallas
they're able to retrieve that content
directly from their closest geographical
location drastically reducing the amount
of time that it takes to retrieve that
content so as you can see here it's very
basic how a CDN is able to provide the
benefits of to the end user by reducing
the amount of time that it takes to
deliver the service but what you're not
seeing here is an indirect benefit is
the reduction in the amount of traffic
that actually hits the Dallas server so
the indirect benefit is that you
actually see a a reduction in the load
or a reduction in the amount of capacity
that you need in Dallas to serve all
these users so another indirect benefit
because of there's this much less
validity and so much less stuff
happening in Dallas because all these
users aren't having to make this make
these trips and I'm also not having to
communicate with with users so far away
the Dallas environment may also see an
increase in uptime and then lastly
because the users are not really
directly communicating with the servers
down in Dallas you have the indirect
benefit of an increase in security
through obscurity so it's pretty basic
to understand how a CDN works in the end
to provide a better benefit to the end
user thanks for watching this overview
of content delivery network if you liked
it or you have any questions please come
below stay tuned for additional videos
in the future and please don't forget to
Like and subscribe